les déchirures du ligament croisé du
genou sont de plus en plus fréquente
chez les enfants à l'hôpital
sainte-justine de montréal
on tente une nouvelle technique
chirurgicale pour les réparer malik nous
en ait mordu de course à pied et de
basket ball depuis plusieurs mois il est
au repos forcé à cause d'une blessure au
genou
l'anti ligaments croisés s'est déchiré
je réussi neuf as for plusieurs fois
mais à chaque fois ma jambe arrachée qui
ça me faisait très mal
étonnamment cette blessure est de plus
en plus courante chez les enfants luis
est de plus en plus fréquent voit une
augmentation le début à 15 % par année
depuis et non dans les dix dernières
années qui sont attribués au fait que
les jeunes font de plus en plus de sport
à risque comme le comme le sourire par
exemple qui ne laisse pas les plus
populaires au québec elle était aussi le
fait qu'il se susurre spécialise
rapidement donc à la place de jouer au
basket de faire plusieurs sports mais
vont focus et sur un score très tôt dans
l'enfance jusqu'à maintenant les jeunes
comme malick et est condamné à vivre
avec leur blessure au genou est une
articulation très délicate en opérant
avant l'âge adulte on risquait de
stopper la croissance de la jambe on
avait la philosophie coeur et son jeune
on n'a pas besoin les opérer ou à la
place d opérer on va plutôt les les
leur faire changer leurs habitudes de
vie donc rester plus tranquille arrêter
de faire du sport et cetera jusqu'à
temps qu'ils aient fini de grandir mais
les enfants c'est difficile de leur
faire changer leur mode de vie c'est
difficile de dire à un enfant non tu
peux pas beaucoup rire tu peux pas jouer
avec tes amis tous à l'hôpital sainte
justine
la docteure marie line nault et la
première au canada a tenté une nouvelle
approche
elle va opérer malik si tout se passe
comme prévu il sera de retour au jeu
dans quelques mois
la docteur no va travailler de pair avec
le docteur guy grimard lui aussi
chirurgie orthopédique
une fois le jeune patiente sous
anesthésie
l'équipe procède à un examen rapide le
genou gauche ne résistent plus aux
mouvements de torsion
[Musique]
donc vous voyez j'ai vraiment une
structure qui arrête le mouvement ici
puis si je vais un petit peu en torsion
comme c'est tout le mouvement est très
harmonieux du jour donc si on fait la
même chose si vous voyez comment le
genou et installe ainsi qu'on voyait pas
de locaux dont le jeu nous met en
relation 3o le fémur et le tibia et la
rotule au centre c'est derrière la
rotule que se cache le ligament croisé
antérieur et le ligament croisé
postérieur et ligaments croisés essaiera
à maintenir la stabilité du genou sur
tous les mouvements de torsion ce genre
de mouvement l'a donc qu'on peut faire
dans lequel se concentrent les sports
avec des changements de direction genre
sauf que ce qui y
c'est dans le ligament croisé antérieur
que surviennent le plus souvent les
déchirures la blessure se produit
lorsqu'on effectue un mouvement brusque
ils vont sentir quelque chose dans leurs
genoux souvent ils vont tomber par terre
ce nouveau conflit
puis rapidement les jeunes vont devenir
assez bien offert peu de physio le genou
va dégonfler rebondir mais mon genou va
bien et nam et il retourne au sport sans
savoir qu'ils ont un ligament croisé de
béchir est privée d'un ligament croisé
le genou n'arrive plus à amortir les
chocs lors des mouvements de torsion
progressivement d'autres blessures
surviennent des déchirures peuvent se
produire dans les ministres ces petits
coussinets de cartilage fibreux en forme
de demi lune située entre le fémur et le
tibia éventuellement car c'est trop
déchiré le ménisque on peut réparer pour
l'enlever
puis l'on ne plus rien tu protèges notre
cartilage d'un genou
sauf que ça fait c'est que le cartilage
disparaît puis on commence à avoir de
l'arthrose en jeu nous fait quand tout
ce processus commence quand on est très
jeune mais on a de l'arthrose très
jeunes aussi et puis là on a des
conséquences
pour opérer leurs jeunes patients les
chirurgie vaut procéder par arthroscopie
une petite incision va servir à insérer
une caméra deux autres vont permettre de
faire passer les instruments également
croisé antérieur normalement donc vous
voyez sincère sur ce report là et là on
n'a rien on ne peut plus rien donc le
ligament et complètement a été déchiré
c'est complètement résorbé dans le genou
l'un des ministres avaient commencé à se
déchirer pour malik
il était minuit moins une juste là où
est ce que mon instrument rentrer mais
celle des choses qui partiel les
chirurgiens prélève un long camp dont
situé à l'arrière de la cuisse
c'est avec lui qu'on va remplacer le
ligament déchiré
on arrive à l'étape la plus critique
pour fixer le tendon au genou il va
falloir percée des tunnels dans le fémur
et dans le tibia
les chirurgiens doivent à tout prix
éviter de toucher les plaques de
croissance saison des fêtes de cartilage
se trouve à l'extrémité du fémur et du
tibia tout près de l'articulation c'est
ici que se forment les nouveaux tissus
osseux qui permettent la croissance de
la jambe
chez les enfants et les adolescents
finis les petits billets destinés envers
les plaques de croissance pour les
enfants si on vient dribbler dans la
plaine de croissance mais ce qui est
réservé c'est que cette portion l'appel
de croissance va arrêter grandir
éventuellement quand l'enfant continent
grande est la genre grandir crush parce
que ça va être une croissance asymétrie
l'on va se retrouver avec une ovulation
du membre inférieur ou encore pire si et
ferme au complet on va voir une jambe il
va être plus courte que l'autre autour
du genou de malik on installe un
appareil de fluoroscopie cet équipement
de radiologie par rayons x va produire
des images des eaux en temps réel sur
ces images on voit bien les plaques de
croissance pour être certain de ne pas
toucher les plaques et chirurgie utilise
un instrument spécialement conçu pour
les petits jeunes ou des enfants et des
adolescents
c'est un guide qui permet de visualiser
en trois dimensions par où va passer la
perceuse
[Musique]
chaque millimètre et critique les
plaques de croissance sont indemnes
on passe le temps dont à travers le
fémur et le tibia
on le fixe grâce à des ancrages spéciaux
pourront faire tenir le greffon dans les
tunnels au sud
[Musique]
si tout se passe bien
malick sera de retour sur un terrain de
basket ball dans six à huit mois
même si elle voit de plus en plus de
jeunes blessés
la docteur no ne décourage pas les
enfants de faire du sport même de haut
niveau
donc il faut être actif et surtout le
plus important c'est si l'entraîneur
propose des exercices pour prévenir les
blessures il faut les faire donc
encourager notre enfant à faire cet
exercice ya les espoirs cet exercice
d'équilibré délégation s'est fait sous
forme de jus mais il faut l'encourager à
les faire